[Music]
um Alexander welcome to the studio today
you made a draw uh first a small
question about the game were you
disappointed that this was a no game
finally did you want to have a chance
with the black today no sir lift oh you
can never be disappointed it was a fast
draw with black after your
um after you lose uh with white in the
previous day and especially I didn't
only lose one game I lost two games
yesterday apparently as it turned out
which is a complete nonsense uh yes I
wanted to ask you Alexandra about this
situation uh well which affected the
whole tournament and you're probably the
player who was affected the most by
hampi's withdrawal so how do you feel
about this now the whole night I mean
we're discussing it and Nana also texted
me because she she also was very
disappointed to say
two like players who suffered the most
and of course I knew about such a rule
but you know I've been playing chess for
like more than 30 years and never such a
situation actually happened in my
tournament and this rule is so
ridiculous because I don't know how it's
supposed to be but you for my like when
you win a game it's like your property
you know you suffered through it you
fought I mean you prepared it's like 10
hours of your life you dedicated to your
game and okay I mean the result can be
different of course but you want it and
then somebody said oh you know
it's not yours anymore I don't know what
is what is the way I know it's a tricky
situation and uh it's very hard to find
like the ideal solution but probably
some players should be getting more or
less but I think there should not be a
situation where you just like taken away
your point or half a point or whatever
and
um well I was very very disappointed in
that but it just before you know the
game I realized it actually I was lucky
imagine if both Canary and hierarchos
Drew then you know I would finish the
game with plus one being on plus one and
I would start the next round being on
minus one I mean this is a ridiculous
situation I don't know it's definitely a
question of course the rules are the
rules you cannot change them uh
throughout the tournament but it just
shows how ridiculous this rules are and
probably they should be reconsidered and
uh actually I've also learned I mean I I
didn't prepare today and I was lucky
that my opponent picked this opening but
um I learned that the same situation
happened in Saint Louis last year when
Carson was due okay only after three
rounds he was Drew and uh but
nevertheless he already won against
Yandy ponushi and Yani publisher I mean
benefit was like the benefit I mean
benefited a lot from this situation
because he kind of almost got a point
okay I lost the point and Nana lost the
point and I mean that's uh it's not only
about points but about as I said the
facts that we like uh spent so much time
preparing and playing and the other
players they're just getting a free
extra day and for me right now like
playing the third tournament in a row
I'm like running on energy so much and
then like points just getting you know
stolen from me that's completely I mean
it it's I mean it just feels uh unfair
okay I know there is a tense price that
is left probably it should be
distributed between the players who
actually play this game somehow you know
four players did play this game and they
did spend their time so yeah I don't
know again it's a very unfortunate
situation of course health comes like on
the first place we know that we don't
discuss it but what we what I try to to
make a point that it's it just feels
very unfair you've finished the game if
you finish I mean already very hard game
right I lost yesterday uh you finish uh
like your situation is plus one and
everything seems to be okay but then you
suddenly realize that you are on 50
percent
yeah thank you Alexandra and we really
hope that Fida will take the situation
into consideration and this will set up
a precedent and maybe a few things will
be changed in the future thank you
thank you Alexandra competitor indeed as
she's really feeling uh the uh
withdrawal and what it means as we